I found a Korean restaurant right here
in North Vancouver so when I finished my
hockey I can come here and study my Kim
Eun ha podcast and enjoy some Korean
food spoke a little bit with the lady
here and maybe when she comes back if
she agrees I'll do a little video but
now I'm gonna get back to my lunch which
is actually quite delicious so here I am
just finished lunch played hockey this
morning still keeping up on the events
and in the Ukraine so listening to a lot
of Russian but I decided to go for a
Korean lunch as you saw earlier here is
here is the place but the waitress
didn't want to be videoed so that was
that hope I got myself in the picture
well we're here in the office because
you know I went to have lunch in a
Korean restaurant and the waitress
wouldn't let me film her speaking with
me in Korean so I figured I'd come here
the nerve the nerve it was interesting
her English was kind of okay and but she
says your biggest problem is that the
grammar in English is different and the
word ordered order is different and she
has to sort them out in their head but
the minute you start trying to start
paying these things out in your head
here you're lost all you can do is kind
of graduate gradually get used to it so
we were talking a little bit about like
there was someone concerned about one of
our French lessons that the text didn't
totally correspond to the to the audio
and I know that the learn allows I have
to consume so many hours of audio and so
many thousands of words in the text
which gradually helps me get used to not
the rules explanations but that total
you know mass immersion if one little
thing like the numbers the things in
Korean that are confusing kind of Korean
it's very difficult because you get
these little words that get that's about
eight different meanings half of which
are contradictory
you know anyway the point is that if you
actually if you notice that there's a
mistake good for you makes you learn
because you there's probably lots of
mistakes that have gone by that you
didn't notice it's fine you people are
doing nice to it the 99% of what you're
looking at is correct that's you have a
long way to go before it's not correct
enough for you it's certainly not gonna
influence you but I think we should
perhaps point out that we have here you
know a little link gathering here our
master modeling Sorcerer's Apprentice in
the background Boris and you know when
we had that lunch and everyone said
Happy New Year in their own language and
I put it up on my YouTube channel one
person identified Bulgarian I think they
said like oh wow it surprised to hear
Bulgarian one person yeah how many
people speak Bulgarian as a second
language but you've learned Korean -
Boris what's your experience been with
trying - it's a struggle I mean for me
at least when I when I took French in
high school it took four years of French
and I remember being in an AP French
class getting AP yeah getting ready to
take the advanced placement test which
gives you college credit versity credit
I'm in this class which is my fourth
year of French and I have a friend of
mine on like hey we should actually
start speaking in French because
otherwise you don't speak outside the
class all you do is you can't learn
to grab her stuff you learned some words
but you don't really use the language
practically and so like three and a half
years in we start speaking French during
at her passing period like for ten
minutes and it was really hard to speak
for ten minutes like we started it up
for like two minutes I'm like oh I don't
know what else to say or how to say
these things and just a lack of
opportunity when I remember like we have
French in Montreal which was in those
days of course Montreal was divided
English French you've never spoken
French we have French for 10 years and I
remember in those occasion II we'd be in
some part of Montreal where they didn't
speak English and I listened to my other
and the focus had been on grammar the
whole time the 16 verbs that take it and
whatever might be when you went to speak
they couldn't could not put the words
all he had was words la Mar je vous
voulez there was no set the grammar that
they had learned could not be translated
into actually using it anyway which also
reminds me while I think of it I was in
San Diego
lots of Hispanic people down there most
of the people were you know doing any
kind of service job are Hispanic and but
if you speak to and a lot of them speak
English I mean they're totally
Americanized even those that speak with
an accent right old now how you doing
you know even with an accent but some of
them have no accent and then you speak
to the Anglos down there and they all
had for six years of Spanish at school
can't speak a word
zero do you understand anything no you
know you turn on you can turn on the
Spanish radio which we do by five
minutes in the Spanish radio listen to
music if you turn on the Spanish rated
you understand no that's quite amazing
actually yeah amazing
not really no not even the track record
of all language programs like that like
the French here I mean I've had French
in high school for ten years and went to
university where there was a language
requirement so everybody had to take it
proficiency test when they before school
started to see
if you pass the princi test you didn't
have to take in language otherwise
you're required to take two years of a
language so they wanted to start me in
beginner in French after 10 years here
but mean even still even still you know
you're not tremendously motivated to
learn math in high school either but I
learn it you know that's a very good
point yeah you do come out with some
knowledge of math or history right but
in French we come out with zero zero
anyway how much you're up to Korea I am
yeah two days two weeks yeah I'll be my
sixth time there but it should be good I
mean it's easy for me to get around in
Korea cuz I can speak the language so I
don't have to have buddy companion to
only translate and stuff
but it should be good a good opportunity
I mean I get lots of Korean from
speaking practice here in Vancouver as
well but it'll be nice to you know see
some signs and stuff in Korean and you
know be able to just have that more full
immersion experience do you have any
sort of publicity stunts plan for her
link to take capitalize oh not really
no we're like naked running naked
through there soccer's former rock star
name is Tiffany plastered on your chest
thank you know a friend asked me to sing
at his wedding so I'll do that and
otherwise I we have our iPhone developer
board as you have she sent you dad was
in Korean and Mandarin now you're doing
Russian which languages are all of them
very similar but Nina your French
actually is quite good a little bit that
I've heard did you have French at school
yeah this like sound is really unusual
for me as well as English are Cassandra
French yes I've heard a small number of
you I've heard a number it's unusual
like from the farm country maybe
everybody makes fun of those guys anyway
so alex is off yep
but you're gonna stick with the
challenge cuz you're doing Korean what a
compound
he already speaks Korean fluently
I mean you know I like the writing is
easy the speaking is easy listening no
problem the problem for me is is reading
because I'm I'm a lazy reader in Korean
and because it has a different alphabet
it just ends up being so much more even
at this stage it's just so much more
tiring to read than reading English like
English it's just that Korean I'm like
ah now I gotta put my thinking cap on
really focus on this and that's the
biggest thing for me we'll do one of
these videos after the 90 day challenge
ends and if anyone is not in the video
you can assume in it they did not
complete successfully their 90 day
challenge successfully just means
staying weather with it I have no idea
how how much better I'm gonna be at the
end of the period successfully ends
meeting your targets you probably
already yeah okay well I'm gonna run
home and work on my career now yeah okay